[Music]  Jon Arryn is dead I know he was like a  father to you John was a man of peace  why kill him he started asking questions  I've heard it said that poison is a  woman's weapon yes women Cravens and  unit that's all the realm is now  backstabbing and scheming and  money-grubbing who but you can protect  the kill  they killed my husband this people will  do anything  all of the power is yours you need only  reach out and take it if we don't act  there will be a war you condemn yourself  with your own mouth seize this traitor  they said they were going to kill you  strike tonight while the castle sleeps  I know the truth Gennaro died fool  [Music]